[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe maybe
[Music]
the pebble sale system is the first and
only saving kit designed for people with
coarse curly hair and sensitive skin get
$30 off a 90-day supply of the bevel
safe system when you visit get back with
a cop slash audible talks face the
online therapy company believes that
therapy should be affordable confident
too inconvenient a talk space therapist
can help put you on the path to a
happier life for a special offer for our
listeners visit talk space.com slash
Hannibal talk space makes it easy to
connect with an experienced licensed
therapist handpicked just for you for as
little as thirty two dollars a week
using talk space you can send your
therapist text audio or video messages
whenever you want we even do a live
video chat and there's a special offer
for our listeners you can use coupon
code Hannibal to get $30 off your first
month and show your support for this
podcast that's Hannibal and talk
space.com slash animal talk space
therapy for how we live today
[Music]
podcast episode 27 Hannibal Burres and
I'm Tony trim yeah we're doing an intro
we usually don't intro
our episodes but I feel like this one
needs one and also I wanted we could
it's kind of like we can have a little
separate thing we record that this is uh
is June 2nd we just watched the Cavs get
rekt get the rent looked excited to play
basketball a couple times he looked like
he was on fast-forward right he was
going really fast he was he was feeling
himself he was going really fast and
going straight to the basket and then
Duncan it was like he's been saving up
energy for this moment he's like you
thought you thought you thought I was
good this is how good I am
check me out now can you my inhale in
the mic that's the first time I took my
inhale on the podcast it's real [ __ ]
puff-puff yeah
puff puff puffing on the podcast so busy
it's a busy run of weekends it's been
[ __ ] crazy
Moke fest no Boston Colin Boston Colin
Boston Colin was fun
it was a little chaotic but ended up
being fun we got a great episode coming
up yeah Danny Brown oh well I got a bit
drunk and so we need to it needs some
editing yeah it needs some there's needs
some tender love and care
it needs some it gotta get some stuff
out of there yeah I said some foul stuff
a bit drunk is an understatement you
have you completely blacked out on that
one what's that yeah that's sort of like
how would a rapper blacks out on the mic
you and he's I blacked out on the mic
that's what they mean I blacked out
you black you blacked out
yeah it was hilarious it was too much
stuff around yeah one point you had to
lay down on the bed you were just like
what the [ __ ] that's what I said
you didn't say what the [ __ ] you just
you just you were in the interview and
then next thing I know cuz you got you
because you were sitting next to the bed
mm-hmm and then you just plopped
yourself down on the bed and just laid
back right and just kind of listen to us
talk for a man that's you pop back up
was like laughter yeah yeah that's the
ultimate co-hosting right there yes
ultimate when the one knows just takes
it has to take a nap mid interview oh
man yeah it was uh there was let's just
say there was two bottles of Hennessy
and like four blunts rolled when we got
in there and that [ __ ] was not there
anymore on when we left yeah I usually
don't smoke during interviews yeah well
before the interviews but you it to be
fair you warned him to use that if I hit
that this interviews gonna take a weird
turn yeah and it definitely did so was
that was that self sabotage uh I think
no I think you did it out of habit
because I think cuz cuz you were
drinking you're steadily drinking so I
think when when you get to a certain
level of drunk and something gets passed
to you you just kind of I guess I'm
smoking though yeah I think that part of
your brain just shuts down
doesn't want to smoke weed part yeah so
be it man so--but we're back in Chicago
for a couple days it's uh it's beautiful
in Chicago it was 79 degrees today I
love is driving in in the summertime and
shot you know how you know how cheesy I
am I was driving in my in my rented
Cadillac and I play good life by Kanye
just so I could hear the summertime
skyline that's not cheese I thought you
were gonna say you're listening
that will smith summertime I couldn't
forgive you for that one I thought that
I honestly thought that that's where
that was going
that you were gonna be like I was
listening to so much so much somewhat
time yeah like that's it bro
well when I'm in Miami I'll bump preach
by Drake cuz he's he started off I'm in
Miami yeah most of these guys it's
massive mm-hmm I need to do some
reflected yeah yeah
oh I'll bump Miami nights about while a
not a very popular song of his but it
was when I was first going to Miami like
2011 or something
anything man hear me nice it was all a
dream
something something I was at wet willies
and then I went to wet willies and I'm
like this is just slushy drinks what the
[ __ ] why like with the wet willies cuz
you said it on a song and it's just
slushy slushy second with the 7-eleven
totally disappointed man you know that
reminds me me and when me and uh
Serengeti were touring will we that was
when that New York song was hot with
jay-z
and Busta well then you know Alicia Keys
and John that was yeah so while we were
driving it cuz we were touring in a car
we're driving it would we put that song
on like like a couple of corn balls yeah
and I gotta admit I welled up a little
bit really good city so big it's so big
and it's all man made you is just huge
and you're driving into it and you hear
new you are yeah you know I used later
they would play that song a lot did not
come out in 2009 or 2010
uh yeah around I think it's one of those
they used to clean it all the time at
Saturday Night Live after parties no
they will always play new yeah they play
that [ __ ] Messiah they're everywhere
people get really enjoy you know what I
used to play that new
York my New York [ __ ] a Busta Rhymes
yeah yeah yeah New York [ __ ] and he was
that Swizz Beatz yeah that's when I was
first visited in New York 2008 or so
nasty used to get me high yeah
where I would play it I had a group of
friends that I made on one of my trips
New York this girl Kathleen will let me
crash at our houses she would have
events on a roof and I will be buffing
that song all the time she's like you
net even from here yeah but I'm on New
York you know you know is it you gotta
admit to like cuz growing up on New York
hip-hop when you first moved to New York
UVC start seeing all the signs and
you're like oh [ __ ] Marcy projects you
like oh you're like connecting the dots
yeah you see the projects you see
yeah Marcy Harlem but they like in
specific streets and your scores and
shin corners and you'd be like oh [ __ ]
what was on the one did he check
sometimes I'm around slow sometimes I'm
right quick I was on 1 2 5 and Saint
Nick
time to lay up everybody I don't like
that song does that you don't like you
don't like the D that I the D the D no I
didn't like that I don't know I just
didn't like that song it was it wasn't
bad but it was catchy okay the D the I
the D the D the Y the D the high D is
did it hold up is did a that's was up
yeah yeah yeah well just to intro this
ever speaking in New York we recorded
this interview in New York I was a
little bit late cuz I haven't been in
New York I misjudged the time I was
actually recording this art podcast
where Abbi Jacobson at the moment oh
yeah and we were walking around talking
about art it was a fun podcast it was
different because they had it was our
audio but they had this guy walking in
front of us with mics so it was kind of
nice to walk around and be loose talk
about different art
and I spotted what's the one architects
name zaza Hadid your turn Zaza Addie
Zaza Addie Hadid no I don't I don't know
I'm not familiar with her work
I got put on by her through
tyro Jones who was a Chicago artist goes
by slang Gizem yeah and he he's who I
bought those the other paintings the
paintings from zaha hadid
excuse me Zaha Hadid and so there was
just one painting that we were supposed
to be all focused on that was the main
painting I've never been to the moment
before we were there towards closing
time yeah and so there was a bunch of
paintings in his room and then it was
just one painting I forget who the
artist was but it was more people just
kind of just standing right in front of
this one hey you know I guess this was
the star of the room which is weird too
is I get I like art but it's weird to
see when it's a bunch of paintings just
seven people in the room just focused on
one and it's kind of staring yeah I
looked at that one s I didn't feel that
and it was his other one I was drawn to
and I like it look like a Zaha Deaton's
and so I hit up
tyro and I said is that it what was the
name of that architect he put me on she
says I D and then like two days later
they honored her on the Google homepage
so when you pulled up Google yeah it was
learned more about to work about zaha
hadid
and then you could click an 8 she died
last year I believe okay but uh it was a
fun little pockets but I was I was late
to talk with you guys you and Jean Grey
yeah and so that's why this podcast
starts all weird with you to the start
of that day in general was a [ __ ]
pain in the ass for me what happened
well on my side I didn't get to go to
the museum and look at paintings and do
cool [ __ ] I they woke me up early and
they said they said I did first of all I
got home that night the night before and
my electricity wasn't working
okay so that sucked so here I am in the
in the dark wash cleaning myself I like
whatever it's 3:00 in the morning go and
sleep wake up electricity still not on
sir then that's how we wake up I'm like
10:00 that's fair amount of sleep I was
about to say you all gonna miss 60
expect yeah yeah and you electricity
should be on anyway yeah well
electricity is lectures anyway so so
they moved me to this tiny room and
that's when you hit me up and you're
like we're gonna do a podcast today and
I'm like well [ __ ] we can't we can't do
it in the room with just a bed and a
chair so I hit the muffler so I need the
upgrade and then it took a while to
switch over blah blah finally got the
suite scrambling put it together
literally had everything set up right as
gene knocked on the door Wow so like the
way everything came together somehow we
made it happen
yeah so I got there a little bit late
yeah cuz of New York raining traffic
yeah but I was excited to have gene on
Hipparchus I was we didn't have a time
crunch cuz she had a show to get to
which we ended up ended up seeing it was
it was a dope event but yeah I didn't
like it was you know I was a little late
and she had to run so I was a little
rush she didn't get as much time it
would have been a lot of fun but she's
super industry she's one of the greatest
rappers one of the greatest rappers in
general I used to spend her vinyls back
in college that's how I got put on sir
back in college and then so yeah I was
been a fan for a while and then got to
know her in New York we've done shows
together she's been on the road with us
a few times and she's a very prolific
person she's always working on [ __ ]
always making music always doing
something different always staying
creative in a various different ways so
we probably had to get her on again and
do another another half because we
didn't get to talk about some other
stuff I wanted to talk about but for now
listen to this app with Jean Grey I'm
late so they they they get mad at me
I got a hurry yet I'm just roll I'm just
gonna go ahead we're gonna go from here
so everything's out the door that's too
late I can't [ __ ] stay till 8:00 break
down hit it
[Music]
[Music]
this is I'm sorry attaboy yeah animals
running behind he's doing I think he's
doing some press stuff for uh hair yeah
yeah no I I thought I had to think about
it for a second oh is that I think
that's him I hear the bell hold on a
second you should just let him wait
there
just let him wait there for like 20
minutes oh man
yeah it's been like half an hour Tony's
great though he showed me a whole new
we're playing with an organelle which
handle doesn't care about no you don't
wherever you we were making beats we
made a whole song we've done an entire
song already play let's play let's play
the song for him again don't add to the
song this is what see I'd never had any
extra like people hanging around no
entourage he's like you make a whole
thing and then [ __ ] show up and
maybe like you're like no
do anything you didn't do any work on
this melody sorry that's pretty close to
a breakdown breakdown breakdown where
you coming from
okay MoMA MoMA yeah so you were just
like hanging out at the Museum no gene
supposed to be there but I really want
to go to the museum 6:15 front us but
it's just a nightmare to get from mid
south of the city
you can't leave no you got to leave at
like 5:45 it's raining and it's like
rush hour right why don't you act like
you've lived here before I've followed
how it's changed you I don't got ya man
I live in Chicago I'm good you look you
look um you look smooth really you look
very smooth in the face I don't know
what I noticed you know what I'm saying
yeah good weeks well yeah I like that
you were just going with it
he's got a rope with stuff in life and
then it's all why is he perfectly in C
major this is a beautiful hotel room in
the room I had before it was better than
I heard about it oh yeah yeah now we're
here this is nice okay artsy it's uh
it's got it I like the balcony it's got
a good balcony gone yeah that's a good
wraparound balcony but it's only got one
chair yeah cuz they're like you don't
have any friends
yeah like they're making was just you
know just for lap dances
how could he let that's like it sounds
like a cool fat guy soundtrack yeah but
but he's confident so yeah
Jane was just telling me that she is an
ordained what pastor no Minister
Minister she's like [ __ ] I run a church
[Laughter]
even here when the podcast started I was
very upset in yeah back of the car yeah
[Music]
get the scheduling right yeah I was uh I
wanted to be on time anyway I have a
church do you have a church now yeah man
I know is it a lot of things have
changed no I haven't seen you in four
months it's been so many things have
changed I don't know if it's been four
months yes well let's do a proper intro
it's a
to our guests and me wow I wanted to
create an attention you know how
sometimes when uh you guys when you
watch a TV show and then it start from
the end yeah and then it show you how
you got there yeah I'm trying to I'm not
doing that but no I with similar with
structure they did they started the
credits like at the end of the episode
and they were like oh that's genius or
yeah maybe they forgot yeah all right
let's do the proper inch okay welcome
oh let's start up starting up starting
up start wow that's weird start boom
that's weird it's weird start it start I
don't want to start up
[Music]
welcome welcome to another episode
handsome rambo podcast I'm Hannibal
Buress
Pony trim who's the best special guest
my good friend Minister mr. Qi okay I
mean whatever I thought well melting
question in the minister part I was more
questioning the Jean Grey but if you
administer I was wondering if you go by
your government as a minister oh right
to the nitty gritty
yeah Church thing started um I wanted to
start Church there was actually it was a
night that this is the last time I can
remember doing it it was a night that I
was opening for you and there was four
month maybe is weird Detroit no it
wasn't it definitely wasn't Detroit in
Philly no it wasn't but I had a long
conversation with this dude and his wife
at the bar and and I'd normally have
these conversations when I'm on tour
like I kind of find someone and I'm like
well what is it you do and I'm like what
is it you really do I know you're not I
know where you work now like but but
tell me like what the thing is that you
want to do that you really want to do so
yeah people about the Drava
yeah yeah and then I kind of Tyler
Durden them and I'm like you know I'm
gonna keep up with you and if you're not
doing this thing like in a you know
certain amount of time then things
laughs yeah no I don't threaten to kill
them yeah yeah and so he he wanted to be
a comedian and I think it was like this
past year or so and he was like
my job I started you know doing shows it
started going out and doing things but
it was maybe the 20th person I had
spoken to over the course of years that
have been like I'm I'm quitting I'm
going to do my thing yeah
and church started kind of around that
idea and around the idea of just doing
shows that I kind of feel like what I do
on stage anyway has been church for a
very long time when you're bringing
people to a moment and bringing people
together if you don't mind me asking
what kind of church is it none I say
nondenominational only like it's a get
your [ __ ] together and especially as
creative people Church Robbins type [ __ ]
yes but it's in a bar okay so we either
do it at union hall or we do housing no
okay you know if you are you're a Jesus
person then you can that's fine you can
do all that yeah if you believe in
nothing um the I the you know the idea
that I did I always talk about is save
yourself so it's like you getting your
[ __ ] together as an adult yeah
people bring their children but if
there's a lot of cursing it's about
adult issues what about origami attic or
recovered attics no no no I wouldn't
assume that that would be a no a lot of
creatives a lot of crumbs because we
talk about you know organizing and
planning or toxic relationships or your
relationship with your mom or like like
this so it's like therapy it is it is in
a way we have an entire choir songs we
do we could it's a it's a real time and
it's on Sunday afternoons I felt like
every Sunday I'm no [ __ ] that
we're second Sunday of every month
it's too much I can't like pull like
writing a sermon is hard it's like a
two-hour long church and I gotta arrange
all the music and have choir rehearsal
Jean I feel you on what you're doing
right now because I used to do this
thing with Hannibal called Sunday
sessions yeah and he was the minister I
was a host but the same thing I'll ask
you as because I don't think as a
minister as a minister do you ever get
into drunken arguments with some of the
congregation cuz that's what I did wrong
with that I'm generally really really
nice about it I what what I didn't know
I guess is how much how much energy it
is to take on from other people yeah
it's it's a lot as people want to talk
people generally like randomly on the
street have been talking to me for years
and I thought I was like I had done
enough to myself to make them not talk
to me just on a visual level but no it
never worked so people bring me their
problems like a lot yeah and so what who
do you top that on so who do you dump
that at home the beep yes no no no I
don't know you still rap I used to
rapping oh you still act
musical career um music in general is
not gonna go away cuz I just you know do
that just now uh as far as like like
whole gene rap albums probably not I'm
gonna [ __ ] not cuz I did it was 25 years
that's the [ __ ] but you know there's a
lot of years have passed this well you
got more [ __ ] to say you got more
experience you know you listen to old
raps I don't know I never I never really
like listen to my self a lot I never did
that just when I have like I've I went I
went back and listened I think but it
was like it was just qualities album
that had come out and the verse on that
but it's nice when I get to do rap songs
now cuz I'm like okay well give me like
60 bars cuz I'm gonna black out for a
while been a while give me room on the
being a bunch of people have said stuff
yeah so I have to kill like at least 20
your freestyle freestyle skills still on
point though I never really cared for
freestyle I'm not I'm I like writing
yeah I like I I'm very technical yeah I
like the art of writing and the art of
crafting things and as much as I'm a
spontaneous person on on other levels
like battle raps or anything I I have
here was my issue yeah nobody ever like
called me out or anything and I was like
well I have so many things to say about
people but then everybody just left me
alone which was probably good for them
yeah what's oh can you give me a sample
a little maybe the bullet points of your
last servant I don't want to put you in
minister more like the truth but I wanna
know no the last because it was it was
we did it on Mother's Day so there were
a lot of people who were like hey either
my mother passed away or then she
couldn't be here
or one of our choir members awfully
alike did a song and like her dad and
her mom were there and it was awesome
they did daddy lessons and he was on the
guitar like that was cool
I was talking about just just general
adult [ __ ] and that I think as you know
kids where we're raised with these kind
of standards and ideals of like this is
what an adult looks like and once you're
an adult and you look at it you're like
oh [ __ ] nobody knew what the [ __ ] they
were doing at any point cuz I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing with that
picture myself and and you don't think
you never at like any point there maybe
there are random things you're like oh
wow that was a real adult thing I just
did right there but it's not really a
thing like being a you know a grown-up
is not something that you can take from
from other people's ideas of what it
should be for you you have to decide
what that is for yourself yeah yeah
because if you just took my a log of my
activities without if that's all you did
just broke down everything I did didn't
tell any you tell a person what uh who I
was or what my age was I guess how old
this person is that's too much freedom
for a 16 year old somebody needs to rein
him in you know but yeah there's there's
not you know the idea and and especially
for creative people who live outside of
what that kind of actual grid is right
there's no way for us to fit into that
like you're supposed to be doing this at
20 or 30 or 40 or 50 it just it doesn't
work like that so kind of giving people
just to let people feel more comfortable
with like it's okay you know I was like
everybody if anyone in this room feels
like I'm an adult I have [ __ ] figured
out I kill it every [ __ ] day raise
your hand yeah and there's you know
there's from children to sixty year olds
in there I was like yet no one usually
how none of us
what usually how many heads are in
Tenon's Union Hall we usually do it at
Union Hall they just had a fire in the
past month so we've kind of been out of
there but it'd be usually packing about
a hundred so and that's not very small
basically yeah so we moved to the Bell
House and I mean for us Sunday afternoon
on Mother's Day about 150 yeah well how
many how many sessions have you done I
think we're on 800 so this is brand-new
no it's just spaced out it's a you know
every oh yeah well lent monthly and we
got we take some time do you I have been
wanting to do that yeah and then the
issue is I don't want to include the
part where people are sharing oh you
know because I want it to be like this
is a safe space out you don't need to be
on on camera or that and well this is
kind of what church is like anyway get
it
Solutions yeah Jesus you don't put a
voice put everybody talk to this mic
would that be and just a shadow
yeah just change the lighting I said I
Love New York because water to spend
more time at home but it was really just
because to easy access to drugs and it
would get real loose out here you my
spare time
Thank You Sharon Jeffrey share on the
Jeff Graham Jeff Greene of Bushwick 107
is his zip code you can also find him on
Twitter at at Jeff Green so do it like
that
brainstorm just pitched it maybe you
know just that idea will float it and
then you think of more prayer in a live
stream it and and kind of just you know
take that part out yeah there is kind of
like Sharon in the middle is good half
an hour sharing their ever there is a
lot of crying
it's a lot of crying Wow yes it's very
emotions are P session basis it's and
and drinking and won't get to drink okay
cuz it's a bar and you know do you get
my thing is let the church say [ __ ] yet
and everybody's like [ __ ] and a
little kids there and they're like
what's the name of the trace called the
Church of the infinite you the infinite
you you know what I uh you post about
this yeah no social right oh I've seen
that not just thought that was just some
concepts not following it Thank You
church yeah it's like a real [ __ ]
Church oh how come where's the next one
uh June 11th to 11th no essentially you
started your own religion basically
see you I may have done that you know
that you know there's a famous quote by
I think it was by l ron hubbard it is of
course it is yeah we're wait no if
you're gonna do an l ron Hubbard
then he said something like if you if
you really want to get rich you start
your own religion well that's a good
dark little twinkle I'm not saying
you're trying to get rich off of it I'm
just but here's the thing which I
definitely yeah I definitely realize I'm
like hey if if I were to be like hey
let's just full-on Jesus this out I
could make a lot of money tempting
sometimes suggest to bring in a Jesus
out of it yeah throw a basket around and
that's it yeah yeah yeah maybe you can
bring the Jesus into it but it's kind of
a a meta thing well you don't really and
you like we loved a loan-out right
no people want full on Jesus yeah full
on Jesus is the only way to go Jesus you
can't like half-ass Jesus you got a deep
throat yeah you gotta go there's more
there's no half-stepping with Gino
that's why I actually I watched Tony
wherever this documentary yeah and I
mean sure this stuff is probably
overpriced but I like the fact that it's
just genuinely trying to push people
that's what motivates people versus just
repeating stuff out of a book yeah
reinterpret lessons based on a book and
and just you know it's the idea that
this is about you it's not about me it's
not about everybody else here I know
that you're coming here because you have
something that you want to do and the
deal is that the world is [ __ ] up but
we can't do anything about the world
until we're like a hundred percent good
with or as close to as we're gonna get
with ourselves and just being better
people we're not all gonna be [ __ ]
Saints or anything but at least do the
[ __ ] you're supposed to be doing and try
to be better so run us through like a
day a day at
like so we start so we walk in what is
it like this is usually a good playlist
going do like a lot of old blues and
stuff before we start and then but you
would not do that right I was trying to
play some blues but I thought that would
do it that would uh it's not like that
at all because that sounds it's not like
Annabelle so don't you don't want to
come to that church and then we do we
start there's a paper Oh plays we always
start with let the Sun Shine in and then
I do a little sermon I do that for about
20 minutes bring the choir on we do a
song okay what's that
what's your sermon delivery cadence
pretty much like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay just talking you don't kind of
put it on no doc no no no duh I start
every Church with being like in it is
this is your first time at church do you
have to fight and then I let it go for a
little while to see if they're like I'm
like not as fine here okay I mean but if
you want to we can set that up
upstairs okay so some jokes and some
things and then kind of just delve into
the issue whatever is the topic of the
week been like Trump Trump Trump Trump
no no it went there for about two weeks
yeah I would imagine so and yeah we we
started like kind of add right at the
time so it was a lot like that those
churches were heavy and at a certain
point it was like okay
and also as white people in the audience
what we need you to do is [ __ ] relax
and get over it like we've been dealing
with this [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time and
we're fine so y'all need to chill and
again concentrate on yourselves we've
focused enough on this we're done oh
yeah all right and so when how many
people are helping you with the
you got me yeah yeah you got no crew no
but I Mary Ann Wayans helps run the show
at this point okay because I it's it was
just impossible for me to you know do
the it's a long ass sermon and do choir
rehearsals pick songs arrange the songs
act as choir director at the same time
so Mary Ann has been great yeah and
that's it's just so this has been taking
up all your time lately she's been like
your main what's been like your main
thing um I have another show at Alamo
Drafthouse that we do every two months
because it's impossible to do more than
that
was it it's me and quasi yep and we take
clips and basically wipe all the sound
from everything whether it be cartoons
or TV shows and dub everything over and
in addition shoot like all new original
material and basically make like you're
flipping through a channel for about an
hour and a half every two months
okay we're cover today it's tonight yeah
yeah what time is that at uh I gotta be
there in an hour yeah so we're gonna go
do that okay yeah is it gonna go past
midnight cuz its but no absolutely not
it's about to be my birthday I'm trying
yeah kick it
oh yeah no I mean there's a bar that you
can start there it's Alamo Drafthouse so
you can drink and watch the movie and
eat let's do it
[Music]
the bubble-shaped system is the first
and only shaving kit designed for people
with curl coarse curly hair and
sensitive skin and with Father's Day
around the corner you can surprise pops
with the ultimate gift in personal care
bevel get $30 off a 90-day supply of the
bevel shave system when you visit get
beveled comm slash Hannibal talk space
the online therapy company believes that
therapy should be affordable
confidential and convenient a talk space
therapist can help put you on the path
to a happier life for a special one for
our listeners visit talk space.com slash
Hannibal talk space makes it easy to
connect with an experienced licensed
therapist handpicked just for you for as
little as thirty two dollars a week
using talk space you can send your
therapist text audio and video messages
whatever you want or even do a live
video chat and as a special offer for
our listeners you can use coupon code
Hannibal to get $30 off your first month
and show your support for this podcast
that's Hannibal and talk space.com slash
Hannibal talk space therapy for how we
live today
[Music]
with the church I want to bring you back
because I am with the first one yeah how
did it go and what did you learn over
time and what did you change um I didn't
I didn't I didn't know what my what my
style was gonna be like I guess because
I'm used to being on stage and I'm used
to talking to people and I'm fine with
doing that and that's great but writing
a sermon is a totally different thing
it's a very different monster it's not
just it's yeah it's not it's not a
lecture is it's not a just a regular
talk it's not a set it's not like but
you have their sparring but you had you
have to inspire people and there have to
be moments you know there's got to be a
rollercoaster of emotions you got to
kind of take them places and then you
got to figure out where it hit hit
points hard yeah oh yeah I learned a lot
after the first one about what not to do
I've tried things I've tried just not
writing anything and being like we're
just gonna freestyle this whole church
and see see how it goes down yeah so
it's it's it's trial and an errand
without letting everyone else know I'm
trying some [ __ ] right now and and
trying to make it feel the same way I
like that yeah I mean the the sermons
are unlike improvisation was a was a
whole week or imagination how important
it is for adults yeah
was the whole thing and then of course
you know we're doing Willy Wonka's
imagination or we do who done James
Blake songs that we do Max Roach and
Nina Simone songs like we we take from
from everywhere and recreation is though
you know that good that's a good point
like I met when you get older your
imagination just kind of disappears
and that's it's a problem yeah and we're
we're always taught you know as children
that this is what you should be doing
you'd imagine this and imagine that in
children and then it's promoted so
hardened and once you hit like a certain
age like you hit ten and they're like
get that the [ __ ] out of here now you
got a start [ __ ] you like yo you just
told me to what every everything was all
good like I supposed to be imagine in
this whole world Remmy get those put
your dreams on the [ __ ] trash so it's
weird girl job get a job 10 chop it to
steel mill I like this day have any has
been eight sessions so far yeah eight
well it's been eight um I went on a
cruise that Joko cruise Jonathan Coulton
cruise so I took Church there but I also
additionally gave a talk Jonathan
Coulton you should check him out yeah
yeah you would enjoy it he's an
incredibly clever songwriter okay yeah
alright have any have any love
connections at your church probably yeah
there's there's definitely been business
connections yeah and one on one on one
connections there was a you know the one
we did on the boat was was about I
decided to take this sermon back there
was what's that thing that you're
supposed to be doing so you know this
girl who makes like detachable sleeves
and she was like I'm trying to sell this
thing or this girl who was writing this
comic book and she was like I really
want to get to it and I'm like you gotta
just she's like I worked for so many
other people but I want to start my own
thing so I think sleeves actually got in
contact someone else was like we have a
store we'd love to carry them right you
know it's it's the point of being like
if you don't say these things out loud
and you're not really doing them that
nobody else knows yeah what it is like
and nobody holds you accountable yeah
you don't miss all your connections
don't miss don't miss your [ __ ] money
either so is
interesting that you say that because in
the Korean community especially like in
the States like the church like wherever
Koreans are very Catholic or a Christian
based and a lot of the business
connections that they make are through
church yeah like some other [ __ ] only
go to church not because of Jesus
business they go there they go it's
Network go there the network it's the
it's the original social network yeah
and you know these are like like-minded
people you all get it and you're like
okay we can we can work together on this
absolutely yeah you pray together and
then afterwards we have coffee and
donuts and juice yeah in the little
cafeteria area and then yeah you got you
got oranges bro these are great you got
oranges just went sure you got oranges
though let's make a deal - got oranges
yeah got orders I got orange peels what
the deal I've got some orange peel ah
yeah I said overpriced coq10 - got a
little orange building they did yeah
that's what I deal with
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you like doodoo or are you a person
who dislike some extra garnish on there
there Bev their beverages their adult
beverages like egg whites would you do
egg whites oh yeah fine I'll have it but
it just reminded me me and my cousin
Percy yeah he sounds like some how'd it
lose my imagination things made up so
Mia Percy yeah it's Charlotte I'm
hanging out with this girl is us three
Shelley and Percy sometimes likes to
dare me to do stuff just to see if I he
try to test me so we have we have in
some kind of drink that has that orange
peel like the the peel in it for flavour
or whatever and he was like I dare you
to take a bite out of that you won't
take a bite out of that because it
supposedly tastes terrible
I dare you to take a bite out of it I
don't know I don't want to men keeps
aldair me I like I like to think that
you guys are also sitting really close
to each other talking exactly this time
[Laughter]
you know what and then I took one this
is chopped on it it just looked a
brightness bad it was it's bitter it's a
little bit especially now and so yeah
and then I took hers and ate it slow
yeah that was though you didn't have to
do that I didn't have to do it but yeah
she responded he didn't expect that yeah
he was like yo you changed
oh I love / Z shout out the words you
don't have to do much he's like old man
I don't even know who you are it's not
the person I grew up yeah you know how
are you I'm good
that you know what that was such a good
response
yeah I've been that was such a great
response especially if you know someone
like I was like Harry and as he was
saying I'm good like heat
he smiled into the words yeah like you
yep
well I've been on a press run this week
so for for wit for which one now for
Baywatch yeah so I did it you're playing
Pamela Anderson just doing a voiceover
stuff yeah a plan is character Dave the
tech I die in a movie yeah I can just
boil it that's just happen getting
pleasure I die in a movie yeah yo so
I've been doing that in my interview
where they brought me on stage at the
Comedy Cellar I told cyber sounds to say
yeah yeah I'm the only comedian who has
spoilers in his intro we were DJ and he
was chanting that [ __ ] to the tune of
trap [ __ ] my future anyway
[Laughter]
yeah it was a fun time other people
would starting to cheer em on I'm very
proud of he's a good night I'm not proud
I'm not bratty a career I'm just proud
of your spoilers do does not care I
don't think they get angry just because
I'm kind of happens early with yeah yeah
and isn't that it's not a dramatic scene
is this Baywatch
it's Baywatch I think that no I mean I I
thought it was [ __ ] fair yeah yeah I
don't die in Baywatch no we all just die
in regular life
[Music]
Moke fest talk about mode fest we ran
into yeah what are you doing there we
just decided to go cuz we usually I mean
it's it's a fantastic place to go at
fascinating oh you bet I've wanted to go
forever we should go next year you have
to I'm down you should do stuff I'm
going to be really like just amazingly
fascinated and and we can make we can
make that happen they were really nice
and accommodating I asked about going
anyway you want to do this you want to
interview this right you want to do this
and what can we just pitch them on group
Oh group yeah just just but just for
like that show especially be special yes
to organelle from yeah okay organelle oh
yeah drums and theremin and theremin oh
that's why I mean that's the main reason
why there's a you got a theremin
we usually have so you usually have a
third
yeah we have I love them very much
yeah it's great I actually have I have
three ther minis yeah it's a great
instrument
it's very do you like have them lined up
and then like play no I have one in LA
and Chicago and I got to get one here
yeah well here's what you have to do is
is line them up line them all up yeah
have you done it before no I played one
but I'm a man bear buddy
no she's right then you would turn that
monophonic there I mean into a
polyphonic yeah that's crazy
it'd be like a choir it's a choir
Thurman's imagine one way not have done
that yet what is one way look at
Hannibal's I mean Hannibal's brain just
about i I just thought I haven't thought
about it either
yeah together if you have three of them
you can't you know separate put a plug
them all into a mixer and just have a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I'm not a choir of therapist but they
call it a murder of theremins I murdered
really no yeah I'm kidding guys I mean
all of it and I made it all
I like that though we you coined it
we're gonna use it we're gonna be like
there it is Hannibal Burres and the
murderous Thurman's yeah it's a murder
of something yeah it's a murder of
something in a guitar of something I
think it's a murder of crows yeah yeah
like a group MoMA ps1 hundred theremins
and you just [ __ ] run around in a
circle and play the theremin
why would that not be a thing can I be
involved in this yes it was not your
idea I got like like we play the
theremin and then and then you tell like
like one joke and then I'll give like
motivational information and then you
just like play but there certainly yeah
it's a circle and you two are in the
center yeah so anytime you move and
every time we do an event we call it a
circle jerk I was I was my voice I was
my voice could convey how excited I am
about this I you've got you you've kind
of gone back into your mind yeah yeah
you're some see I'm picturing myself I
already see it like it'll be a white
stage to master theremin it'll be a high
up stage like a weird kind of high up
stance and I wear like kind of a linen
outfit you could pitch this to MoMA
very very Eric Benet literally much
linen like the way drugs dad looked at
that party yeah
I don't ever have to be there to know
how big that was top to bottom like oh
yeah yeah like like sometimes you can't
tell if it's the stage or if it's you
yeah like that's magical yeah I wanna
yeah this is gonna be great
this is this has been this has been good
well I did such yeah are you still you
doing any acting or doing stuff doing
your sitcom anymore um
I've got a bunch of things ready to go
but it's really you know tough to have
to do all of these other things in the
meantime and then be like also so yes
there are two very very fun long-form
ideas that I'd love to sell and kind of
pitching all the time which is a fun
monster going to the pitch meetings yeah
I really like that you like pitch me um
yeah yeah I I yeah I enjoy the play I
enjoyed the play that's the first time
I've heard of guests say that for the
most part they're just like I hate doing
this [ __ ] yeah you enjoy it I do yeah I
like um I like I like talking to people
as much as I say that I don't
yeah I kind of like the the the back and
forth deal of it I like the let's make a
deal situation right and then I also
like to be like well alright then I
don't care bye-bye
mm-hmm yeah oh you go in do you have a
go pitch with someone or is it you and a
managers just use a us I've gone just as
myself a bunch um I go with with Mary
Ann now where is agent no right no Mary
Marion is managing me now she's managing
you down but we'll see you agent she
wasn't agent for uh for Gersh okay
yeah Vanessa he's managing you she is
okay I think we both kind of look at the
situation where like do you want to just
I mean we're clearly
like doing this anyway yeah so let's
just and if and if we don't work out we
don't work out but let's she's like I
just want to try to help out and you
have a lot on your plate
yeah I would really [ __ ] appreciate
that I got a new show with John Hodgman
starting on the third on June 3rd yeah
yeah Oh what we just decided we want to
take it somewhere and we don't know what
we want to do as a show so we're just
gonna try some trial runs a live show a
lives we're gonna start it as a live
show and John Hodgman sounds like a
union hall we're gonna we're gonna do
that and then go yeah on the road and
figure out what the [ __ ] show is okay
yeah it was working title gene and John
all right all right yeah it works
Gina John do so gene and John do
something do stuff well maybe you know I
don't know if this is traditional show
creation process but maybe you should
start with the song and then you work
from dinner you know no change
CNN's own Gina John gene and John Cena
hmm I'm trying to think of something for
y'all to do but everybody's done most of
the stuff well we're looking at it so he
has his show he had a yes secret society
and I have the show show and and I think
we've just been spending so much time
like kind of being at each other shows
we're like why don't we just you know
just do a show so I think we're going
with the two desks one guest Oh like a
competed talk so almost yeah yeah yeah I
like that that's interesting yeah and so
is it combative playfully combative
sometimes it happens we've been you know
their interest is when we've been
playing Scattergories on it's it's
mostly me yelling yeah yeah you know
it'd be a good idea if you if every show
is you and John arguing and then your
guest is the moderator and then you and
then the moderator at the end decides
who is the winner that could happen it
could be a segment I think we're - we're
too friendly to debate but it's
definitely I think we both talked really
long but something for some reason hands
up I end up being super straight man on
it which I'm definitely not everything
we could make that happen because that
what's the friendship without a good
debate I love that book what book what's
a friendship without a good debate
that's your book that's my book yeah
okay see this is from the future yeah
I've got so many ideas today if you ever
want some ideas and you want to get out
there and do [ __ ] you are just a breath
of inspiration yeah thanks mm-hmm
DJ premier last one that aired was what
shark Allah circular okay how's that
your circle is a Chicago legend these
sales yes miss Ellison you know
chocolate I know of
he sells been selling CDs and stuff on
the street yeah everybody knows him in a
city so we just talked about his history
just music and just a lot of weird stuff
and then got he got bit by a spider I
got bit by a spider I got a that it
caused a lot of damage it was terrible
what happened I got bit by a spider I
didn't know what it was and I had just
traveled to Australia and by the time I
got there we were two days into the tour
and my foot started swelling up and I
was like I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on but I can't walk they figured
out what kind of spider bit you they
never figured out what kind of spider
but by the second week my foot was so
huge and they were like oh yes it's a
spider bite it was spawned by a spider
bite goddamnit Australia and they were
like probably in your shoe that's crazy
y'all know what I was doing when I went
no but we have to leave music muscle
memory like that it was in your mind boo
boo it's so I could do the beat with it
to speak a little more professor wait
you performed as though I do yeah yeah
yes it's a good it's a good throwback
song to do stage and also yet there are
those songs that are like it doesn't
matter what kind of state I'm in or like
if I'm ever concerned I'm like I'm gonna
forget lyrics it's one of those songs
that you're like nope that's just always
[ __ ] in there I can do it backwards
forwards whatever yeah yeah yeah Jean we
gotta do a whole album with just organ
now I'm down for everything I'm also
down for pitching this theremin show we
got this festival show for your book
which you don't even remember the name
of by now oh my god see what's the
French say without a good debate Thank
You Hannibal someone was listening okay
now remember okay I gotta go I gotta go
I gotta get oh my god we got to go to
the shadows go what sorry it starts at
9:00 it starts at 9:30 but I got to make
sure that everything's okay okay so you
guys don't have to leave but I have to
leave okay are you guys start drinking
yeah they have a whole bar yeah yeah
it's about to be your birthday it's
about to be mom do you talk about ages
do we talk about
yeah um be 36 oh [ __ ] yeah good one I
lived to eighteen that's good
I've lived two lifetimes where I can buy
porno and cigarettes I like that that's
the way you're thinking about it I was
not thinking about that at all before
Noah born over 42
a little bottle yeah good for you
hey we're gonna buy you some some double
porn we'll send it to you I'm gonna do
that's polio I've gotta get to hustler
today little hustler oh good for you
good look at this guy all right
all right G how would I know you say
goodbye we are going this is the first
time we're all leaving first time would
guess what we just bouncing I think so
we still have to do some work well the
thing you guys have to go what is it uh
all right okay check it all right honey
are you singing this on to show it's
done is ready in the yard the [ __ ] is
grew
[Music]
you know
I'll walk today sila good to me
it sounded fine it was a beautiful song
thank you thank you for finally having
me on the show
great
[Music]